all right an unusually a low number of a
turnout here tonight but we do have one
person a nice new face love to see it so
we're going to get this thing rolling
and tonight I'm going to go back there
was a request a while back for the four
nights defense so that's what we're
going to go over tonight and so the four
nights begins with the moves efore 'if
I've Knight f3 knight c6 and now instead
of the Royal Oh PES or the Spanish or
the Italian or even the scotch white
picks the fourth most popular move
Knight to c3 and I think this is a move
that a lot of beginners kind of find on
their own it's the kind of thing that
when you just sort of know opening
principles but you don't really know a
whole lot of theory it's something that
you might just come up with so I have
several students that you know they
don't know any theory but they just sort
of discover this on their own okay so
yes so this is something that you don't
see a whole lot at the top level and I
one of the reasons is is because black
cannot really equalize the game in
several lines rather comfortably almost
universally black will play Knight to f6
and so here you have it the four Knights
I wish my my three-year-old were here so
I could confirm but I believe that those
are four Knights so all the Knights go
to the logical squares which doesn't
really pose black too many immediate
problems a lot of the times when white
is getting his Bishop out earlier he's
trying to cause some problems before
black and get his pieces out in Castle
but here normally he won't have any
problems developing his pieces so the
there are a couple moves here the most
popular moves are Bishop to b5 which is
the Spanish for Knights we'll look at
that there's also the Scotch for Knights
which is a close second and there's even
the move g3 neglect system so we'll take
a quick look at that but I do want to
point out one really common mistake that
I see a lot and that's people try to
play
the Italian for nights and this is
actually a mistake already because a
black can employed the fork trick so we
only have one person in the audience but
we'll see if he knows the fork trick or
if anyone else all the people training
for the camera can help them out
excellent
yeah Knight takes e4 so you'll notice in
this position white has two pieces that
are set up for a pawn fork when there's
two pieces next to each other with the
space in the middle
sometimes a pawn can fork them but here
this wouldn't be a really good fork
because you would just be losing your d5
pawn but by taking first with the night
you're coaxing out the white player into
taking back and now hopefully you see
the fork d5 and so this should win some
material and black will end up with a
better position for example if Bishop to
d3 black can take but also what's funny
is he can also not take based on the
fact that even if you give white a
chance to move this night away you can
still play e4 on the next move and trap
them so you could play the untested
Knight to b4 which would be funny
the computer is like yeah that's a good
move you can also play f5 which has been
played before and then e for next but
okay most people take the knight seems
to make a lot of sense and now you get a
position where black has an easy time
getting all of his pieces out that's why
he can't possibly be worse and efore is
a really awkward square for this dis
bishop he's not feeling very secure
there so we'll see and we can just go a
couple of moves farther down the line
here all right white does have a little
threat he's going to take on c6 with
check and then he's going to take the e
pawn so black usually defends his pawn
and then people castle and okay the
problem is this is kind of a weirdly
placed piece and black gets his pieces
out comfortably so some people when they
they see this position here and somebody
does take their epon they think to
themselves okay I know that he's going
to fork me so I'm going to take the
opportunity to take on f7 with check and
misplace your king
this is actually a worse variation for
why
so he he shouldn't go in for this so you
take and they take your night and here
you can just get the really big center
with d5 and even if the night gives you
a check you run away this is actually
significantly better for black and it
might not look that way at first because
you know you're just you're looking at
this king you think that looks kind of
weird but black already kind of has a
lot of ways to get pressure so if white
just casually castles for example you
can play h6 and follow it up with an
immediate Bishop to g4 and white is
already under tremendous pressure and
this should be really bad for him and I
have a lot of students that they seem to
like to play this variation a lot and I
can't convince them otherwise
so I shown a lot of my private students
six different games from a grand master
named afro may of and okay maybe for one
of my beginner breakdowns when I do
begin to break down in April I'll go
over afro May of games from this
position because he's always when people
played this way he's always taken done
the fork trick and people have either
taken his night or taken on f7 and he
gets really good positions and he's
always won and he's had some games were
there about 20 moves against relatively
high rated grandmasters so it's not a
very very good way to play and I have
another student that I keep telling him
stop doing this like you know it's bad
and she does no she's like yeah I know
it's bad but people never take on e4 so
I keep playing it and I get good
positions so if you're playing absolute
beginners ya chances are they're not
going to take on e4 and then yeah then
that's a good move you followed up with
d3
and then life is good but if black knows
what's up he'll just take on e4 alright
so we'll go back to the starting
position here and we'll mention briefly
the Gluck system this is named after
Igor glocca Grandmaster who's really
made this his own system it's sort of
unusual at first sight you might think
okay you already moved your epon now
you're moving your Jeep on so the f3
square is a little little tender now and
you know you're going to put your bishop
here which might seem strange because
you've already put upon in the way but
what is anticipating black's future
plans and black is going to play
in the center he'll get this night out
of the way and he'll play c6 and d5 and
get some pressure on the center and in
the queenside so he's thinking by the
time you do that then I'll be able to
take on d5 with my pawn and then my
Bishop will be looking really good also
there's a there's a lot of different
things we can do in this position
oftentimes you'll see then I going to h4
followed by a quick f4 that's very
possible
another common maneuver is that you get
your pawns on h3 and g4 and the knight
comes over to g3 where he's looking at
the f5 Square which would be really nice
for a king size attack so we'll we'll
take a little look at this here and okay
the move d5 that is a possible move here
but the main move is Bishop to c5 which
seems to make a lot of sense you just
get your Bishop out and then you're
going to play d6 next but my question is
you've lined up these pieces so can't
white just do the same thing and do the
fork trick
I'll let the audience see if they can
play the next couple of moves here an
audience of one is all you need
okay the first move right here yeah okay
and then you're going to let him take
this sudden quite work
yeah the first move is the you know sort
of the very obvious right you okay you
just take the thing but now what if d4
tossa yeah perfectly said
so yeah in this variation because the f3
square was weakened with the move g3 you
don't have the fork trick available to
you so very good yeah what do you have
we have one audience member that knows
all the answers that's all you need yep
so the torque trick does not work here
for white but after Bishop to g2 now he
is thinking about the fourth trick so a
few castles Knight takes e5 is a fine
move to play but black has time here
just to protect so again now white could
easily castle here or you might think
about playing the move d3 and the most
accurate move here is actually to play
d3 and I have a lot of students when I
show them this position and they say
well shouldn't you just castle you know
Castle early Castle often we even have
an expression for this but you're in no
immediate danger the reason for the
always castling as soon as you can rule
is because some beginners they don't
castle then their King gets made it in
the center in this position you know
black has no way to open up the center
immediately and you are one move away
from castling if that becomes an issue
in the future but the move d3 sets up a
small positional threat we're just going
to try to get a small advantage after
this move by playing the move Knight to
a4 and trying to get the bishop pair so
that's why d3 makes the most sense so
black will usually play a six so that
now you have a retreat square and yeah
so the game will just follow sort of
normally now we can even throw in a
couple more moves these things seem to
happen and we can just talk about that
the basic plans and strategies here
so yeah often this bishop will go to III
that's sort of part of White's plan he
doesn't mind if you trade it on III and
I have to take back with my F pawn it
does open the F file
I do get doubled pawns but it is an
extra central pawn so normally that's
not a big issue and okay sometimes we
have the maneuver as we've seen before G
4 and then the knight can come around
and jump all the way into f5 also you
might play Knight to h4 and when you're
not in a pin play the move f4 and get
more space on the King side and black
meanwhile usually will maneuver his
Knight to g6 or it still controls the e5
square and then he can play c6 and d5
and get something going in the center so
a really interesting game what he's
interesting about this position that
surprised me when I prepared this
lecture is the computer actually thinks
that black is a little bit better here
which I don't know if I agree with that
it seems like pretty equal it's a really
balanced game so both sides you know
have have nothing really to complain
about here so that's the Gluck system
alright so we'll go back once again to
the starting position and we'll talk
about the other two most common ways of
playing will actually save the Scotch
for Knights for last because there's a
game that I want to show that made a big
impression on me when I saw it live and
we'll talk about the main main line
which is Bishop to b5 and now it's the
Spanish for Knights so it's a lot like a
Rui Lopez
only these two nights have you know been
moved to these squares and normally the
knight in the Royal Lopez doesn't go to
c3
normally the knight is back on b1 where
it can go to D 2 to F 1 to G 3 to i f5
here he still might get there via
another route but ok it's an interesting
way to play and the most common reply is
Bishop to b4 and we have sort of a
double Rory Lopez I do want to mention
the possibility however of playing
Knight to d4 this is an interesting move
to really try to imbalance the game and
this is the Rubenstein counter gambit if
you take on e5 which is not very popular
black can play Queen to e7 and due to
some pressure on the e-file you should
be able to swap a bunch of pieces and
achieve an equal game so white will
often in this position try for a little
bit more and you did attack my bishop so
usually they just move their brush up
back
all right makes enough sense and black
continues in the spirit of the gambit
Bishop to c5 so okay now I will take
this and if you if you Castle white
already has to be really careful on this
next move here
turns out castling is actually already a
mistake and now suddenly white is in a
very bad position and will see that it
doesn't really look like okay you have
all these guys you have a queen that
might be able to come in later you're
about to play d6 and get your bishop
into the game do you really have an
attack though it's hard to see it but
after d6 if you go back to f3 then you
have to worry about this pin which is
going to be really annoying because he's
going to shatter your your pawns over
there so more commonly they go to d3
attacking the bishop looks pretty good
but now black has a winning attack so
I'll once again see if I the audience
can find it this is a little bit tougher
and at home you can go ahead pause your
video see if you can find it as well
nothing yeah it's quite tough so in this
position there's very strong move the
first move that you should play is
Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen
you really can't play f3 because I have
so many discoveries that win so okay
fine I'll just move to e1 and now here's
the really all-star move they any
defined to win the game here ah I say
some random move maybe that's right
Knight takes c2 it's probably not the
best move okay
yeah just joking all right we got an
all-star move here you see it yep that's
a black to move
mm-hmm yeah Knight to f3 which is a very
strong sacrifice so if you take here
black takes back and surprisingly you
have no way of stopping the threats of
Knight to g4 and Queen to h4 where
you'll be threatening to mate here as
well as sometimes you have some threats
to come down and mate on g2 and you can
try to figure this out for yourself but
there's absolutely no defense to the
attack so it's a yeah it's a very
surprising way but you can see if you
play this variation you can get to a
trouble really fast for white if you
don't know what you're doing and you get
that caught off guard so I will go back
and yeah so more common white shouldn't
Castle here you should just attack the
bishop and when the bishop goes back he
5 which forces the knight to sort of an
awkward Square he's got to go back to
the clumsy e8 and now after castling you
get a oh sorry actually I think yet
Knight to d5 might also be the move here
to go get that Bishop but you get a
position in which you know you're up
upon is white but you have sort of
awkward problems with getting some of
your pieces out and some of your pieces
are not on the ideal squares so black
should still get a lot of pressure and I
think this is probably equal but it's it
should be more enjoyable to play this as
black at least in my opinion you know
some people they like to be up pawns but
it's it's a comfortable position for
black so you might want to consider
playing this way if you face the four
Knights often enough but we will go back
here and we'll go back to the main main
line the main main line and this is a
version of the of the four Knights
that's really really boring and dull and
so that's why a lot of people they just
think the four Knights super boring
never going to play it because they they
know the main main line in here both
sides castle and then both sides go like
this and there's there's so many ways to
play for example after the Bishop to g5
not the only plan but one plan for black
to try to imbalance the game is to take
the knight and now he has a
very interesting you know not the most
common way of dealing with this pin
Black's big problem in the mainline is
okay you got a deal with this pin do we
really want to you know kick the bishop
away by moving all of our pawns well
probably not so there is a unique
maneuver of bringing a knight to e6 to
make sure that Bishop has to go away so
for example Queen to e7 and white can
prepare to start pushing in the on right
in the center of course he could take
here and get a super ultra Josh line but
okay if he plays for a little bit more
then you get this maneuver play in the
center and you can attack our Bishop so
yeah so very very interesting and now
you're going to like the the most
popular moves here so watch White's next
to moves very often this Bishop will
retreat all the way there's not a whole
lot of better squares if you go to e3
you might get attacked later with Knight
to g4 so not the optimal squared
I mean d2 doesn't make a whole lot of
sense but it is playable actually so
okay the bishop goes back to c1 nice and
safe and not the only move but black
often plays the move c5 in these
variations and white will try to keep
the tension for as long as possible and
only if necessary play the move d5
because after you play d5 you really
might start to feel the effect of the
doubled pawns over here but the most
common move here for white is Bishop to
f1 so get your bishops out there and
then bring them all back that's that's
how you play good chess and all right so
let's put like one more move here for
black and you know there's a couple ways
to play it there's actually some
interesting games that have been played
in this variation and one common plan is
g3 and then you get to play for f4 and
you try to get a lot of space over there
before you do all this you might have to
play the move d5 and blacks just going
to try to keep a lot of pressure in the
center and eventually get stuff going on
the queenside and so this is a very
interesting way to play but I will go
back and I want to look at a different
line that's a little bit more exciting
and that's the
four nights so again this is sort of
like a scotch but both players have
already agreed to put their Knights on
c3 and f6 and okay usually they take and
we'll look at the most common move which
is to take back which is the obvious
move but I do want to mention the
possibility of the Belgrad gambit and
somebody mentioned that they wanted to
see this which is kind of one of the
reasons I decided to show this whole
variation but then as I was sort of
going over what I would want to cover if
we went over this gambit I realized this
is going to have to be its own lecture
because you know there's so much they
can go on here there's already four very
common moves and that's a Bishop to e7
Knight to b4 and both Knight captures so
hopefully we will get to go over this
they're probably gonna be some month
where we just go over gambits and that
this will definitely be be one of those
that goes into there so very exciting
but we're going to look at the main main
move here and in the game that we're
going to look at today in just a minute
here we'll look at the move that keeps
it sort of an independent territory here
Bishop to c5 the most common approach is
to play Bishop to b4 and now we've
transposed into a well known line of the
Scotch
so from here you've played typically
continues with taking the knight so he
is threatening already to take you're a
for pawn because of the pin so typically
you take and then you protect your pond
and you get a position like this where
okay they get to unbel and everybody
castles and you get your Bishop out and
that you know stuff like this tends to
happen and black and go back to e7 he
can also go back to d6 and it's a well
known line from the Scotch so you can
expect to see that a whole lot but we're
going to get to our main game here and
we're going to see a slightly different
line all right so this is the game
between kramnik and Aronian from 2012
and it was played in April of 2012 which
was two months before my son was born so
I used to be able to
watchful tournaments so I was watching
this whole thing it was a really great
match it was erroneous Kramnik they
played six games and you could tell from
the beginning they both really wanted to
win they both took lots of risks and all
the games and so was a very fun one you
know they could have just agreed to both
be really boring but they didn't it was
a really fun event and Aronian ended up
winning it even though he didn't win
this game so it was round three kramnik
was behind a point he really wanted to
win and in a surprise move I mean when
you're playing for a win you don't
expect to see the four Knights
especially from Kramnik who usually
plays d4 Knight f3 on move one but he
did and another surprise he played the
Scotch for Knights so probably just to
get his opponent out of prep and get
some some position here and now Bishop
to c5 ok and he played the the main move
in this position which is Bishop to e3
it's quite possible to take this Knight
this will also lead to typical scotch
lines position like this you can imagine
so this also was a possible move but the
most popular move here is Bishop to e3
which already sets up a little little
trick white is hoping to take this
knight attacking the Queen and exposing
an attack on c5 so there's already a
threat so the bishop has to go back now
he's nice and safe and from here he did
sort of an unusual plan something that
had never been seen at the top level and
there's almost no Grandmaster games with
this move but he played Queen to d2 and
so his plan is to Castle queenside and
to play f3 and then get sort of a pawn
attack and so it reminds me sort of of
the yugoslavia tack in the Sicilian
dragon or an English attack on the
knight Orff where you you know you get
this pawn formation in your Castle
queenside and you start rushing these
pawns down the board to checkmate your
opponent only the difference would be in
the Sicilian this pawn would be on e7
and then we'd be asking ourself how the
Bishop got on b6 and we'd probably think
that we're watching a Scholastic
tournament
so here the pawn structure is slightly
different but it's the same idea
and so he castled castles and he put a
lot of pressure on the center with rook
to e8 so okay f3 this was my plan and
black got to play a tic typical
liberating move d5 so it's looking
pretty good for black so far you pretty
much have to take my pawn you can't let
me take on e4
so I'll take take back and it looks like
we're going to get some trades and black
is going to get this Bishop out and
everything's fine but already an
interesting decision here Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen so so what will
black do here he actually played an
astounding move you probably don't want
to play the move f6 even though it might
be playable you might be able to get to
an end game where you're slightly worse
but maybe you can survive because after
this move you're really weakening the
King so I move like Bishop to c4 becomes
really strong and okay you gotta do
something so you can take my knight
I'll take threatening discoveries so you
have to get out of that and amazingly
even if you get to this end game where
you give this guy away before taking on
b6 and we trade all the stuff and you
take here and I don't let you play rook
a1 you might get to some endgame where
black is clearly worse because he has
more weaknesses but it is a rook endgame
so these are notoriously drawn so well I
mean you could have played this way as
black but it's obviously not the end
game you want to play against Kramnik so
okay I doubt he ever considered f6 very
seriously
another possible move is Knight d2 e7
but what should get a slightly better
position just by trading and after you
trade Queens
you can play Knight to d5 you're going
to pick up the bishop pair and have a
slight advantage but okay certainly that
was a playable option but he played in
this position the much more amazing
Knight takes c3 ignoring the threat to
the Queen
so it's a queen sacrifice and white
accepted it and now black takes on d1 so
for the moment he has a knight and a
rook for the Queen
but everything's hanging so you get this
incredibly difficult position to
calculate correctly there's so much
stuff going on but just to illustrate
one way white could already go really
wrong here is if you take on d1 and
after rook takes d8 you play a move like
c3 and in this position there's lots of
really complicated ways for black to get
an advantage but perhaps the simplest to
understand is to take and take with your
bishop now your bishop is going to get
to go to a nice safe square you can play
a move like c5 protect your bishop and
really control the dark squares for the
rest of the game so in a position like
this black would be easily better so you
got to be really careful already as
white and so in the game we go back
he played Bishop takes e7 and black took
Peck and again you got to be kind of
careful because if you take on d1 what
would a black play in this position
got a little tactic here there's all
sorts of little tactics that both
players I had to see throughout this
game
yeah no idea okay Bishop f4 check
forcing the King over and now you can
take on d4
the point being that you you can't take
the knight or this move will be
disastrous so yeah there's there's quite
a lot of ways to go wrong so both
players really had to care calculate
carefully so here he instead took on c6
all right and now he had to know about
this move Knight to e3 and again white
can get into a lot of trouble if he
doesn't play the right move here
a move like Knight to d4 which seems
normal my knight was attacked if you
move it it actually runs into Bishop to
f4 which is a pretty big problem for you
so he's threatening some discoveries to
win the Queen even if you get your King
out of the way he can take on f1 and
okay you can't really take this because
again the row comes to the back rank so
there's all sorts of possible problems
in this position that he had to sort out
so white played again a really amazing
move so black is happy like okay if I
just get to take your knight next you
don't have a way to prevent Bishop to f4
then you know he's thinking he's doing
pretty good but now the amazing move
Bishop to b5 the point being if you take
and he did that now you get to fork the
pieces you fork to Brooks interesting
enough this move is no longer effective
notice how now the bishops gone so we
don't have to worry as much about back
rank issues and so you can even play a
move like check and then wherever the
King goes play g3 and now white is
completely winning so obviously black
couldn't have taken the night because
then he would have to worry about back
rank issues so a lot of complicated
things going on so instead he decides to
take and white takes back okay
so the queen is attacked she's going to
go somewhere and there was all sorts of
possible Queen moves here they lead to
really complicated lines but the move
that he played was fine Queen to d4 and
soon I'm gonna you know go get one of
your rooks so he developed his bishop
and okay we took the rook on a a okay
simple enough and now black could easily
just take back on a eight which perhaps
he was expecting but he played the more
complicated move Bishop to b6 and
Kramnik just went back to d3 so one
question I remember I had during the
game it was really fun watching this
live I was trying to figure out well
what happens if the Queen protects the
bishop you know that seems like it would
be good but now there's a really really
complicated drawing line that's like
supercomputer ish but okay he could have
just seen that black it's enough
compensation after this check and you
must go to d1 I'll give you a little one
a little tactic here that hopefully even
the audience can see yeah right so a
little fork here so okay that's
unplayable instead King goes to d1 and
now after this capture also like rope to
d8 is also possible and black its
compensation but okay forcing the King
to the e-file so black our white has a
king and a queen on the e-file black has
a rook there so some interesting stuff
can happen after you attack the Queen
you can go back and there's all sorts of
you know bishop discoveries that might
lead to crazy complications and so yeah
you can play like Bishop to e3 and then
it's like an incredible drawing line
that I doubt they they saw but I'm
assuming even if you saw a position like
this he's like yeah black clearly has
some compensation here and just in the
fact that the pieces are not well
coordinated for white and you know he's
all those pieces are going to keep
getting attacked so he decided okay I'm
not going to play Queen to e4 you know a
nice practical decision so
you just put the Queen back and black
decided okay now I can take the bishop
and let's see so you do have three
pieces for the Queen which in theory
that's you know better for the three
pieces at least in general but white has
a huge Trump here and that's he has a
three on one over on the Queen side
which means he has a definite plan in
the future
he's pawns are going to go like this
that's his plan and it's not really easy
to see how black will ever make progress
in this game he doesn't have any you
know super big plan that he can come up
with and so white was really patient
from here on out it was a really
instructive way to play just rookie one
get your piece into the game you're
threatening now to take the bishop and
remove the defender over c4 so after
this the Queen moved and it's so really
obvious how black is going to make any
serious progress here and then he played
a really strange move g5 and this was
something that both players did a lot in
this match they kept playing g5 or g4 in
positions like this and sometimes it was
really good and sometimes it's just
weakening here it's just sort of
weakening the Kings side it's it's not
the best move but okay he's trying to
get a little space over there and now
white can at any moment he can play a
move like h4 and try to undermine the
center in there in the phone call
somewhere but okay instead white was
really really patient in this game first
he played c3 just to get some control
over d4 make sure none of your pieces
get to go to that square and after
further moves again you can play h4 but
he's like you know why not just just
take my time rule out anything go in to
d2 very patient black has nothing to do
and now okay h4 again or the much more
patient g3 and then he's going to play
f4 f5 so yeah okay black is going to you
know try to cramp these pawns over on
the Queen side here's the plan we get f5
and okay yeah again Queen to d3 pinning
the pieces and now b3 so yeah blacks
best advice to trade you want to get as
few ponds over there as possible after
the night moves away okay the computer
line here might not be the best line so
let's already this is a pretty
complicated position he's trying to get
the b3 pawn and if he gets rid of these
pawns
even if it costs him a little bit of
material whites real practical advantage
of pushing his majority would end so the
computer wants to play Queen to b5 but
black maybe has a fortress after Knight
to b3 and night to d4 which you know he
trades his Knight to get those two pawns
out of the way and even if you end up
trading these rooks then okay you still
might have a hard time breaking through
here there's three on three that you
have to break through and he has two
bishops so this might be a really hard
position to defend so he decided to play
much more practical and human move to
eliminate the possibility of a fortress
rook to e8 so sacrificing in exchange to
get this bishop and now we're protecting
b3 and so we can keep pushing our ponds
all right
the Queen was attacked he's got to go
somewhere where he's protecting b3 so
okay he went to b5 and after this now
he's he's ready to start pushing sorry
actually gets his King up okay very nice
and all right now we can push and we can
push and now okay the rook goes over and
now a nice little move g4 just cementing
the position and making sure there's no
little tricks and may perhaps Iza he's
hoping that on to move like c5 maybe he
can sacrifice both of his pieces or
something but uh he had to move now here
come the pawns and goes the Queen
keep going he takes the bishop now it's
okay because even if you get b5 you
played a nice little move here Queen to
e5 and now this rook is eternally pinned
so that piece is just stuck and after
just a couple more moves here black gave
it up so yeah there's really nothing to
do even if you play Knight to c6 for
example we just move our Queen away we
can bring our King in as much as we want
and black should run out of moves so
alright he's like alright had enough you
know you can always white can always
wait as much as he wants and he'll be
able to push this pawn when he's ready
but so yeah a very interesting and
exciting game I was a lot of fun to
watch live so hopefully you guys enjoyed
it at home as always keep sending in
your submissions for what you guys want
to see next week make sure you hit like
subscribe you know all the good stuff
alright thank you